things can change very quickly as we
close in on the first votes being cast
in the 2020 Democratic primary just look
at the last 24 hours which have been
very good very good for senator Bernie
Sanders yesterday I told you 24 hours
ago I told you that Joe Biden had picked
up some support both nationally and in
Iowa in recent polls the good news came
in a big wave over the last 24 hours for
Bernie Sanders and let's go through it
we have a new national poll a new
California poll and a new hypothetical
matchups poll against Donald Trump to
look at let's go through them one at a
time starting with the national poll the
big story a new CNN poll has Bernie
leading nationally the poll says Bernie
27 Joe Biden 24 there's a three and a
half point margin of error so
technically it could be tied but again a
shift in momentum in the direction of
Bernie Sanders in this same poll
Elizabeth Warren is polling just 14 if
we are to believe recent polls we really
have a two candidate race right now this
is really Biden and Bernie one of them
will be the nominee if we can believe
recent polls if recent polls can be
trusted Elizabeth Warren is all but out
of this thing not polling in second
place anywhere unless you go all the way
back to an IBD poll that is like 15 or
20 polls old at this point in time we'll
get to more of that in a second next new
polling out of California we're in a
University of Southern California
Rossier School of Education poll that's
a mouthful bernie is leading Bernie 28
Biden 24 now what's important to
understand about California California
is a huge state population wise many
delegates to be had from California but
very unlikely that California will be a
difference maker in the primary I'll
explain why California apportions
delegates in proportion to the
percentage of the vote that different
candidates get so if Bernie beats Biden
28 to 24 they get a very similar number
of delegates out of California 20
24% respectively if the numbers are
flipped it's still a very similar number
of Delegates for the two of them so
California is important momentum wise
it's a huge state and for PR purposes
it's important but understand that you
know in 2016
Bernie lost the California primary to
Hillary Clinton but he had like 46
percent of the vote and got roughly 46
percent of the delegates this time
because it's a bigger field Bernie may
win but actually end up with fewer
delegates than he did in 2016 but that's
for the future once the first four
primaries are out of the way we'll look
at California in more detail and then
third and maybe most interestingly we
have another one of these hypothetical
matchup polls where people are said if
the nominee were Bernie how would you
vote on Trump vs. Bernie if the nominee
were Biden how would you work on trunk
how would you vote on Trump versus Biden
and the results are compelling this is
from survey USA consisting of more than
four thousand registered voters the
numbers are fascinating the person with
the biggest lead over Trump is Bernard
Sanders 52 to 43 Trump - 9 against
Bernie Biden is defeating Trump by 7 in
the hypothetical matchup Bloomberg
leading Trump by 6 Warren leading Trump
by 3 Buddha jej leading Trump by 3 but
with more undecideds Andrew yang leading
Trump by 2 even Tom Steyer is even with
Trump the two candidates that lose to
Trump in the hypothetical matchups Amy
Klobuchar and Tulsi Gabbard losing by
the most Trump ahead of Tulsi by 5 which
will anger a small but loud portion of
my audience so what's the takeaway
knowing that the establishment is going
to run a full-court press for Joe Biden
throughout the primary what this tells
us is we've got a real race here and the
races Biden versus Bernie when it comes
to facing Trump Bernie is regularly
doing the best against Trump
compared to other candidates that
shouldn't be ignored when we think about
electability unless someone
can explain to me how Warren is still in
this thing I don't see her having a path
to the nomination so my question to you
is can we now say that this is almost
completely a two candidate race Biden
versus Bernie or do you still see Warren
or anybody else having a path to the
nomination I also can't restate the
importance enough that the we want to
have a primary that doesn't hurt our
chances of removing Donald Trump so
yesterday i talked about hillary
clinton's comment that nobody likes
bernie and her hesitation to say she
would support bernie if he is the
nominee
that's the self-destructive garbage that
is the last thing we need the absolutely
last thing we need right now let's get
out there let's support the people we
like based on their policies let's vote
let's then rally around the removal of
donald trump a very solid couple of days
for bernie sanders reminder my question
to you is warren still in this thing she
seems to be out to me but i want to hear
from you we will continue our coverage
of this on our instagram page make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me at David Pakman I
know that the David Pakman show audience
is full of curious and creative people
who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking
that class reflected in my Instagram
pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-sized
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll